hi my name is paracosma Cassie I'm part
of the kernel development team here at
Wolfram research today I'll be talking
about mixed integer convex optimization
and its various applications thank you
let's get started I'm gonna talk about
mixed integer convex optimization Rob
and Nina have spoken at great length
about convex optimization and so just
for the benefit of of anybody who hasn't
didn't get a chance to attend their
presentation I just want to give you a
quick overview of what convex
optimization essentially means so when
we're talking about an optimization
problem we're basically talking about
minimizing a certain objective which is
this F not subject to certain
constraints and what makes a problem
convex is that these functions F naught
and F I they follow this this this
condition this rule and one of the
important things is that when a problem
gets classified as a convex problem as
Rob mentioned you know the solution that
you get is going to be a global solution
it's the best possible solution you're
going to get and so there are so in the
in the framework of this convex
optimization you know there are
different models that come up so you
have linear optimization you have linear
fractional quadratic second-order cone
semi-definite and depending upon what
your objective is and what your
constraints are they they would fall
under one of these categories so if you
have linear objective and linear
inequalities it's a linear optimization
okay if it's a quadratic optimization
then your objective is quadratic but
your constraints are linear semi
definite you have a linear objective but
you have these these constraints which
which are called as linear matrix
inequality where all these A's are
essentially matrices and it's subject to
this cone which is a semi definite cone
which means that after you take all
these matrices and combine them with
these X coefficients that resulting
matrix will be symmetric
positive-definite all right so since I'm
going to be talking about mixed integer
notice that the vector X the unknown X
that we've specified for these
optimization models are all real right
what differentiates this from mixed
integer is that the sum of the
components of your unknown vector are
going to be integers well some are going
to be real nothing actually changes in
the objective or the constraints right
all all that is changing right now is
that the domain in which the solution
vector lives is going to be sometimes
it's going to be real somehow some of
the components are going to be real some
of them are going to be integers but
when a problem gets defined in a mixed
integer of course a lot of it doesn't
always enjoy the same status of the of
it being able to be solved fast because
it becomes an np-hard problem many times
so but nonetheless it can still be
solved efficiently I'm going to first
talk about linear mixed linear mixed
integer linear optimization
okay so mixed integer linear
optimization you have linear objective
and linear :
constraints okay the way you would be
you'd be specifying that in in
Mathematica is through our you know this
this built-in function called linear
optimization which solves specifically
these kind of problems the difference
now is that you can when you give it
symbolically you can just say that
certain elements are going to be
integers and some are going to be real
or if you are giving it in the form of
you know matrix vector forms then you
can specify that you know the first
element is going to be real second
element is going to be integer so on and
so forth right the linear optimization
is it uses branch and cut method in
order to solve the integer problems one
thing I do want to mention is that
linear optimization supports arbitrary
precision computations but only for real
variables when the mixed integer case
comes in it only does it in machine
precision so
so how would we go about solving certain
problems here's just a very simple
example you have you have an equal you
have you know linear objective you have
equality constraints and inequality
constraints and you are going to just
say that we want one of the elements to
be an integer right and that's basically
all there is to it there isn't there is
no other gymnastics that needs to be
done from a user's perspective you just
need to specify what elements are
integers and you're pretty much done
okay we do allow the users to specify
them specify this exact same problem you
know in this matrix vector form because
sometimes you might have some legacy
code that uses this form for linear
programming so you could so you know
it's convenient to use it that way so in
this case you know the first element is
an integer second element is real get
the exact same problem the exact same
solution right okay so really without
going I won't go into the details of the
algorithm associated with linear
optimization branch and cut is prima
well documented out there so I you know
I I'm gonna skip that part what I do
want to talk about is how does this
translate you know we talked about
quadratics second order cones semi
definite optimization how do we
implement the mixed integer support for
all these other functions and we're
going to do that by converting all of
our problems into this conic
optimization form and Rob talked a great
deal about conic optimization and you
know conic optimization is this general
umbrella so if your problem is linear
quadratic second order cone semi
definite what-have-you they can all be
converted into a conic optimization
problem so if we if we develop an
algorithm or a method to solve mixed
integer conic optimization problem then
that translates to us being able to
solve mixed integer problems for all the
other cases okay so I'm going to now
start focusing on chronic optimization
problems and what goes into for it to be
able to solve mixed integer problems
okay
so just a quick recap
you have for a mixed integer chronic
optimization you have the objective
which is linear your ex is your unknown
you have equality constraints and you
have these conic constraints and nina
talked about that about you know the
different kinds of cones that are
available and of course some of the
components are going to be real and some
of them are going to be integers and
these are the different cones that are
available right so if if you're all you
have in terms of your cone is a
non-negative cone then technically it's
a linear optimization problem which can
which I can send off to linear
optimization to do its own thing if it's
if you know the cone contains non norm
cones then it could either be a
quadratic optimization or it could be a
second-order cone problem a second-order
cone optimization right so one caveat I
just I should mention this because the
because quadratic optimization just
deviates a little in terms of its
objective that quadratic objective can
actually be using certain
transformations can actually be
converted into a second-order cone
problem okay so which means that even so
so it falls into the same category even
though we have to perform a couple of
extra steps in terms of the
transformation alright so how do how do
we go about solving a mixed integer
problem well we use what is called as an
outer approximation method and this was
this was developed by Miles Lubin and
you can you can look him up his his MIT
theses is is available online it's it's
very readable what we basically do is we
take the original mixed integer problem
and we break it into two subproblems the
first is a linear sub-problem which only
solves so it only takes into account the
linear objective any equality constraint
that it has and this little special
inequalities and these inequalities
actually come from the conic sub problem
okay so for now I'll explain what this
beta is in just a minute
but for now assume that this beta is
available so you have a bunch of these
half spaces that are available to you
and you go ahead and solve this linear
sub-problem okay once you solve this
linear sub-problem you then extract some
of the components that are actually
integers and you substitute them back
into your into your chronic relaxed
subproblems so the integer values are
substituted back into there so that that
implicit integer constraint is removed
and you solve that problem once you
solve that problem you then extract the
dual associated associated with all
these chronic constraints and from that
dual you compute this this half space
this beta that gives you that's that so
from there once the beta is constructed
you go back so all the linear
sub-problem get the integer value
substitute back in you get a new half
space you substitute that back in
iterate till convergence that's that's
basically what we do okay in case that
was not super obvious clear I'm going to
show you an example because I'm pretty
sure it wasn't here all right let's do a
simple example all right that's the
chronic original chronic optimization
problem okay we I'm gonna break down the
steps everything that I just explained
to you I'm gonna try to show it to you
in a graphical way the first thing we're
going to do is we're gonna solve a
relaxed chronic problem okay notice that
X is not an integer here nothing has
been specified okay I'm going to extract
the primal and the dual from it if you
want to see the numbers let's do that
okay so now now that we've taken out the
dual now we have to form that beta that
half plane that I mentioned and the way
we do that is we use use the dual cone
associated with the constraint and so
that's the H plane is what I've computed
so what does it look like of course
okay that's what it looks like so that's
that this semicircle thing that you're
seeing that's your feasible region in
which your you're supposed to carry out
your optimization problem and the the
half space plane is this line with
everything below it okay so now that
we've computed this half space plane we
plug that into our linear optimization
problem which you see right here just
pull that up and you specify that the X
is an integer okay that gives you and
then you extract the integer value from
it once now that you know a first guess
of what the integer value is you plug
that back into your original chronic
optimization problem solve again and you
get a new result okay and now you form a
another hyperplane and that's your
second hyperplane so the first one was
that horizontal the second one is that
more diagonal right now now you have two
two planes you substitute both of them
back into your linear optimization
problem and you get back a new value
let's see if I can get back a new value
negative one which is simply the
solution that we got in the first place
right so in this case the linear
optimization actually gives you an upper
bound on on your on your primal minimum
value and your conic sub problem gives
you a lower bound and when the two of
them match up that's when convergence is
achieved and you stop your iteration
this is exactly what we are doing behind
the scenes a little bit more efficiently
obviously but but you but you get the
idea
so that's that's basically our outer
approximation algorithm I should also
mention that Nina pointed this out that
mosaic also would do that it uses a
completely different mechanism to do it
so if you have mosaic licensed online
you could use that alright
so what exactly can we do with mixed
integer I mean it's all well and good
that we can solve this but you know what
what mixed integer allows you to do is
opens up a whole area of modeling that
would that would ideally not be
accessible so for example if you want to
I mean I've given a whole bunch of lists
here I'll just go through a few just to
get just to show you what kind of tip
tricks can be done let's say that you
have a variable you know you want it
either to be 0 or you want it to live
within certain bound well you can do
that by introducing a binary variable
which takes on only a value of 0 and 1
and is forced to be an integer and you
multiply that with the bounds so when Z
becomes 0 X is forced to be 0 and when Z
becomes 1 then it will lie between this
one this is Tec typically won't be
possible if you will just do regular
chronic problem because it's a it's not
a continuous you know that the space is
not continuous here's a let's let's
focus on the third one you know doing
our statements this becomes extremely
handy when you are doing things like
path planning avoiding you know when
you're when you're doing optimization of
a car moving through obstacles for
example these kind of or statements
become quite important you either want
one constraint to be satisfied or the
other but not both okay in that in such
a case you again introduce a binary
variable and you introduce this large a
large value called M whether were these
methods where you start seeing this
capital M all over the place these are
called Big M methods which is similar to
what you would do when you're when
you're doing simplex programming as well
right so M is a large positive value and
in this case if Z is 0 then the the
first constraint is satisfied if Z is 1
then the second constraint is satisfied
the another way of looking at it if you
stare at it long enough one of the
constraint becomes redundant right
depending upon which variable gets
switched one of the constraint becomes
redundant so they're they're they're
multiple different
formulations and tips and tricks that
can be used to to enhance the scope of
the problems you can solve using the
convex optimization framework okay
enough theory let's let's jump into some
application examples pseudocode let's
solve the Sudoku problem okay this is a
typically hard Sudoku problem because
and I think it got it got a lot of
tension because because the number of
knowns is quite small we're going to
solve this using the mixed integer
approach and the way we're going to do
that is each element in our pseudo KU
board is going to be represented by a
nine dimensional binary vector right so
it's a nine dimensional vector it's
going to cut each element then that
vector is going to be either 0 or 1 and
the way we are going what we're going to
do is whatever element becomes nonzero
that is the number that will get
assigned to this unknown value okay so
for example we know this is 5 so there's
a 9 dimensional vector associated with
this block and the 5th element there is
one everything else is zero ok so that's
our base now that we know we have that
in place so let's go ahead and these are
all very fast so I'm gonna go ahead and
so that that's the first constraint
right now
the rules of Sudoku say the rows and the
columns should all you know no number
should be repeated which means that from
a binary vector standpoint if I were to
add any row or any column they should
all become a vector of ones right so
that's what we're going to do that's our
row concern at a row constraint a column
constraint and sudoko has a third rule
which says that the three by three
blocks should also be should also should
not have any repeated elements in them
and that's our third constraint now
we're going to collect all these
variables and we are going to now
specify with the constraints that were
given to us you know all these known
digits so we substitute those in and we
solve our linear optimization
problem let me just go ahead and make
this so that you can see it better so we
solve that and whoops and that's a
result and it happens quite quickly
right in the documentation we've
actually taken it a step forward and we
you can actually we have actually shown
you how to develop your own Sudoku
solvers so you can do the inverse
problem the the process is so fast that
you can actually run it so quickly that
you can actually generate your own
unknown Sudoku boards so have fun with
that
all right a second example which is a
path planning around obstacle let's say
that I have a an object just some random
object right what I would like to do is
there's going to be a start point and an
end point and I want to find a path that
goes from the start point to the end
point without going through this object
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
is this we can extract the half-space is
associated with this mesh with this with
this object because it's a complex
object we can extract the linear
inequality constraints associated with
it we're going to specify a start and an
end point there we have it right it's
we're going to start at the bottom and
we're going to try and work our way top
right obviously it can't go through a
straight line so we have to find a path
around it so what we're going to do is
we'll we'll discretize the path by a
number of points right so we'll say PIR
the number of intermediate points in
between and we're going to use ten
points so between the start on the end
there are going to be ten points or
eight points ninth and the tenth are
going to be the edges and what we want
to do is we want to minimize the
distance between the subsequent points
right so that is equivalent to
minimizing the path distance
and using you know the this epic of
transformation we are going to convert
this problem into a quadratic
optimization problem so that's our
objective our objective here is some of
ti-ti so that becomes your your
quadratic objective okay we now specify
our end points which is the start and
the end right and now what we are also
going to give it some additional things
to make make our life a little easier
which is to say that you know make sure
that no two points are too close to each
other otherwise you know they might get
grouped together you might not get a
good result so you want to separate
those points out and you know evenly
spaced them through the path all right
so here's the here's the actual trick
the formatting got a little messed up
but that the actual thing is if I go
back here what we wanted to do was to
formulate a path which means that all
those discrete points from the start to
the end none of them should lie inside
this right and the condition that is
required for any point to lie inside
this is that the linear matrix
inequality that ax dot B right this aa8
dot P I dot B should all be greater than
or equal to 0 if and if any one of those
conditions get violated it means that
the point is outside the domain and
that's that's exactly the constraint we
want to put in okay and the way we do
that is again using this binary
variables so for each one of your points
discrete discrete points we are going to
assign a binary variable and we're going
to say that the total of those binary
variables should be less than M minus 1
where m is the length of T or linear
inequalities in there so we've we've
chosen that M value to be ten years so
that it's large enough but it's not too
large that things go all haywire there's
a little bit of you you'd have to M as a
user-defined variable so beware you'll
have to play around with a little bit
I'm going to solve this quadratic
optimization problem I'm going to let it
it takes a few few seconds for it to get
the result because it's it's
it's it converts into a chronic problem
solves it and that solution process
actually takes a bit of time and there's
your result and there's your path now
Rob and I have butted heads on this
graph over and over Rob says that this
is not mathematically correct as an
engineer I say that's correct and that's
it's got to do with the fact that it's
passing through this point here but but
nonetheless you can see you can see a
trend happening if you increase more
points it's going to that this gap will
go on reducing you know and eventually
it'll come the other the other way you
would do a path planning problem like
this is you you take this and you make
it slightly bigger and you make it
slightly bigger and run the same problem
and then you shrink it back it'll avoid
that obstacle that's that's that's one
way to do it right okay so one more
example I guess which is your graph
coloring problem which is a very famous
problem so you have all these nodes
connected by a graph and you know how
many colors does it take to color that
graphs so that no two adjacent nodes
that are connected to each other will
have the same color so this is a graph
coloring problem I'll start with six
colors I'll generate a random graph and
the objective is to start putting colors
on each one of them so that there's no
no two adjacent nodes have the same
color so I'm going to extract the
adjacency matrix from it this is the
condition that says that you know no two
of them are going to be of the same
color and we are going to use two binary
variables in order to to to set up our
modelling problem okay that's so the
same color constraint says that no two
nodes will be the same and then we say
that if one of the nodes is assigned a
color then that color will be part of
our final set of color
we specify our binary variables in this
case notice that X is a matrix and it's
got a dimension similar which is the
same as our binary matrix sorry
our adjacency matrix and Y is a binary
vector that's associated with the number
of colors I initially decided to use and
we run the problem this turns out to be
a linear optimization problem and linear
optimization is generally pretty good oh
looks like I'm over the limit and we
solved that here's the total number of
colors which turns out to be what you
need and there's your result so I've
just about run out of time here so if
you have any questions please feel free
to ask you have a question great I'm
glad you guys enjoy this
[Applause]